was ich noch ganz kurz sagen muss bevor
es losgeht also das was ich gleich im
video sage beziehungsweise schon gesagt
habe ich meine es nicht ernst also ich
denke er sollte verstehen dass viel ist
da von ronis führt euch nicht
angegriffen oder so keine ahnung
irgendwie so ich wollte nur schnell
sagen also viel spaß beim video
hey was geht ab märz willkommen bei
einem neuen video immer wieder auf einem
kanal und so ja ich will eigentlich
heute direkt mal mit dem thema
durchstarten deswegen fahrrad für mich
das auch gleich mal und zwar geht es
heute um dinge die mädchen
beziehungsweise frauen an jungen bzw
männern nicht verstehen
allerdings habe ich jetzt doch noch für
kleine in von euch bevor wir jetzt
anfangen und zwar hab ich jetzt fehlen
das heißt ich werde versuchen so viele
videos wie möglich im rauszubringen
keine ahnung ich halte nicht an
irgendeinem festen ablauf para so schaut
einfach immer wein und dann seht ihr
auch ein neues video gibt oder ob es
kein neues video gibt auf jeden fall
würde ich das eben gesagt haben und ja
sonst sind es erinnert mich auf facebook
keine ahnung wie es in der beschreibung
aber dann fangen wir jetzt natürlich
auch direkt mal hatte ich wünsche euch
natürlich ganz viel spaß also ihr kennt
das doch bestimmt wenn mädchen oder
frauen keine ahnung ich gehe einfach mal
davon mädchen aus ein mädchen sich
darüber beschweren oder aufregen dass
jungs immer zu spät kommen schließlich
müssen wir ja gar nicht zwei stunden
eher aufstehen um uns 10.000 mal zu
duschen weil es dann nach dem dritten
mal immer noch nicht gut aussieht und
dann halt noch hier diese schminke
scheiße drauf und die augen dass wir
schön aussehen
was sind dann so die gründe zum zu spät
kommen ich denke auf jeden fall mal es
gibt kaum jungs die halt immer pünktlich
sind beziehungsweise überhaupt
irgendwann mal pünktlich sind außer es
geht halt um irgendwelche total
wichtigen sachen auf jeden fall hat
natürlich auch jeder junge andere gründe
um zuschauer fürs zuspätkommen ich kann
euch jetzt einfach mal so meine erzählen
würde ich sagen es gibt nämlich auch
noch wichtigere dinge als ausgerechnet
euch für uns jungs hier auf dieser welt
bei mir persönlich ist das eigentlich
ganz einfach als oder nicht zu spät
komme dann esse ich gerne vorher noch
was oder ich schlafe halten und schlafen
geht halt manchmal vor und essen
natürlich auch also also denke ich immer
ihr seid hier die einzigen die irgendwie
ein halbes jahr zu spät kommen dürfen
weise jetzt nur gerade fünf kilo
schminkt in ihr gesicht klatschen müssen
5000 mal duschen müssen auf jeden fall
die einzigen die ahl zu spät kommen
dürfen hier können sie auch einfach mal
lassen euch 10.000 linke
ich bin ich werde jetzt ein bisschen zu
aggressiv lieb ausgedrückt ihr könnt ihr
auch einfach mal eure lange hygiene
etwas naja unterdrücken sage ich mal und
halt dann mal pünktlich sein und dann
könnt ihr natürlich auch was sagen aber
vorher halt nicht so kommen wir dann
auch schon zur nächsten sache die halt
mädchen an jungs nicht verstehen und
zwar ja ihr wundert euch wahrscheinlich
oft oder öfter halt mal warum wir viel
schlauer signalisiert wo ich versuche
schon seit über drei wochen insgesamt
sprecher auf einem handy zu löschen aber
irgendwie kriegt das gar nicht hin und
ach so vielleicht brauche ich internet
dafür oder eher kommen gemeinden was
schon fertig du hast jetzt das internet
dazu genommen hast du ja cool danke und
dann kommen wir es auch schon zur
letzten sachen und zwar wundern sich
mädchen immer darüber warum jungs nie
heulen oder warum sie es nie zeigen
wollen oder warum es ihm generell
peinlich ist zu weinen zu hinzu rum zu
jammern
ehrlich gesagt ist es auch eine relativ
gute frage aber ich glaube ich kann
darauf eine antwort finden also vor
allem die jungs im alter zwischen 13 und
17 jahren würde ich jetzt mal sagen da
denken halt einige sie werden oder
müssen irgendwo unter beweis stellen
dass sie die grenzen sind wie zb auch
ich so und hingehört natürlich immer zu
seiner eigenschaft da ist man dann
irgendwie ja das ist ein bein ich das
will man nicht zeigen weil man ja
der kurs ist aber das frage ich mich
dann auch so ob das medial juckt weil
wenn er mal hier gelang gestern heute da
eine und da eine ist durch das nicht
peinlich oder findet ihr es irgendwie
gar nicht schlimm würde mich mal
interessieren deswegen wär's geld wenn
jetzt einfach mal unten in die
kommentare schreiben
so leute das was in sachen leider schon
wieder mit diesem video ich glaube es
ist ein bisschen kürzer geraten als die
andern aber wenn ich jetzt so pro woche
zwei bis drei videos raushaut dann
werden die natürlich immer ein bisschen
kürzer aber ich kann auch umso mehr
themen ansprechen auf jeden fall wenn es
euch gefallen hat wenn ihr mir ein
bisschen recht gibt dann würde ich mich
natürlich ziemlich über einen daumen
nach oben freuen wenn sie nicht ganz so
gefeiert auch einfach daumen nach oben
und keine ahnung schreibt mir mal eure
meinung dazu einfach und in die
kommentare auf jeden fall schickt
instagram ich hab dort bei 1000 follower
oder so cool wenn ihr folgen würde alles
in der video beschreibung und hier unten
links geht es jetzt weiter mit meinem
letzten video ja dort ging es um seinen
fragen und antworten wie du ich hab mal
wieder fragen beantwortet und hier unten
rechts
da auch erst einmal dinge die du niemals
zu deiner freundin sagen sollst rein auf
jeden fall check des beines abkühlt mich
freuen und wir sehen uns dann bald schon
wieder schöne fehlt auf jeden fall an
alle die jetzt glatt ferien bekommen
haben und voll rein